the war of the airwaves is almost as
important as the battle on the ground
and the message in this footage from the
ukrainian military training with uk
anti-tank missiles in the west of the
country is of readiness
joe biden has now warned in a call with
the country's president there is a
distinct possibility of a russian
invasion next month have you decided how
soon you would be moving us troops to
eastern europe
i'll be moving the u.s
eastern europe and the nato countries in
the near term
the uk strategy of deterrence and
diplomacy is stepping up a gear with a
call expected between boris johnson and
vladimir putin before the pm travels to
the region early next week
liz truss who met the nato secretary
general on monday will travel to moscow
in the next fortnight
and defense secretary ben wallace here
in berlin on wednesday is due to visit
allies in eastern europe
but not all conservatives are convinced
the west has looked somewhat disunited
from a russian perspective there's never
been a better time to invade ukraine
something putin has been wanting to do
for a long time he's enjoying this
international attention every time a
leader puts their hand up and says i'm
going to go to moscow to try and talk
this of course he's going to say yes he
is spinning this out i doubt whether any
invasion will take place until after the
beijing olympics china would have made
sure of that this is our cuban missile
crisis moment and we must not blink
whitehall may have been focused on one
political crisis for weeks but here at
the foreign office they've been trying
to prevent another the pm wants to be
seen as a statesman spearheading the
west's efforts this is also a convenient
distraction from domestic disarray boris
johnson is vladimir putin's fifth uk
prime minister and it's perfectly
possible the russian president will soon
get a sixth
as further russian military vehicles
arrive in belarus boris johnson has
asked his defense chiefs for further
options to be used if vladimir putin
does what so many fear joe pike sky news